Trascrizione: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Questo è il Manneken Pis,
il bambino che fa pipì.
OK, traduzione del tutto inutile,
me ne rendo conto.
Comunque, si tratta di una statua
di circa 50 centimetri,
posizionata non troppo distante
dalla piazza centrale di Bruxelles.
Si raccontano storie
anche particolarmente fantasiose,
sull'origine di questo simbolo;
ma certamente rappresenta un po'
lo spirito scanzonato, e irriverente,
degli abitanti di quella città.
Ma non è di questo bambino
che voglio parlarvi;
piuttosto, di un bambino in carne e ossa
che, all'età di nove mesi,
si trasferisce proprio in questa città
insieme alla sua famiglia,
con quel flusso di carovane migratorie
che dal sud d'Europa muovevano
verso le miniere di carbone
dei Paesi Bassi.
Lì il bambino prese
il suo imprinting culturale,
anche attraverso lo strumento più potente
che l'essere umano abbia inventato,
che è il linguaggio.
Certo: a casa lui, tra le mura domestiche,
parlava agevolmente italiano
con tutti i suoi parenti;
ma la lingua formale e strutturale
che imparava, scritta e letta,
era propriamente il francese.
E cominciò molto in fretta,
perché la madre aveva l'ossessione
che i suoi bambini dovessero
arrivare alla scuola primaria
sapendo già un pochino leggere e scrivere.
Non che questo disturbò
il bambino, a dire la verità,
che nella scrittura trovò in realtà
una forma di espressione,
una forma di rappresentazione
della sua dimensione
e attitudine artistica.
Il bambino scriveva continuamente,
dalla mattina alla sera, appena poteva.
E scriveva storie fantasiose
che raccoglieva in questo
suo taccuino rosso,
tutti i giorni, scrivendo tutte le sere
prima di andare a dormire.
Storie fantasiose,
e anche personaggi particolari,
come il Cappello Parlante,
molto prima di Harry Potter;
o come l'anziana signora
che aveva una seconda bocca
nel palmo della sua mano,
e tanti altri.
Ma come spesso succede,
certi cicli della vita si interrompono
perché ne inizino degli altri,
E fu così che i genitori del bambino
decisero di ritornare in Italia.
Ma per il bambino non fu
un viaggio di ritorno;
per il bambino fu un viaggio di andata.
Lui stava lasciando tutte le cose
che aveva imparato ad amare
fino a quel momento,
tutto il suo mondo.
Arrivato in Italia, dovette anche
sperimentare sulla sua carne
come un'abilità generatasi
e sviluppatasi in un contesto
in un altro possa diventare,
paradossalmente, un limite.
Sì, perché lui questa lingua
non riusciva proprio a impararla:
continuava a pasticciare con le doppie,
infilava consonanti mute
in fondo alle parole,
poi aveva ancora conservato
quella "R" francese un po' bohémien,
ma che in realtà lo rendeva un po'
lo zimbello, diciamo così, della classe.
Poi c'era una maestra,
forse non proprio una brava maestra,
che lo assillava continuamente
sulla necessità di ridurre
il suo divario didattico
nei confronti dei suoi compagni,
cosa che lo faceva sentire
molto insicuro ed escluso.
Succedeva una cosa
particolarissima, nel bambino:
che più tentava di schiacciare
questa nuova lingua dentro la sua testa,
più la lingua originale
si rattrappiva, si annichiliva.
E in qualche modo, rimase orfano
dello strumento di relazione più potente
che abbiamo a disposizione,
non solo nei confronti degli altri,
ma anche nei suoi confronti,
nei confronti del suo talento.
Fu così che il suo
taccuino rosso si chiuse
e il bambino cominciò a scivolare
dentro una tetra malinconia.
Noi siamo fragili.
La fragilità è la cifra
della natura umana.
Provate a pensarci:
noi siamo l'unico animale in Natura
a non avere una specialità.
Non abbiamo un pelo lungo e folto
per resistere al freddo;
non abbiamo artigli e zanne
per cacciare in modo efficace;
e non corriamo veloci
come la maggior parte
dei predatori in Natura,
nemmeno Usain Bolt.
E allora, come siamo potuti
arrivare fin qui?
Che strano scherzo ha fatto la Natura?
Come abbiamo preso in giro l'Evoluzione?
Siamo un bluff, siamo un errore?
Per provare a rispondere a questo domanda,
devo portarvi in un luogo molto lontano,
in un tempo altrettanto lontano.
Chi vuole può anche chiudere gli occhi,
e provare a seguirmi.
Siamo nella steppa africana,
2,4 milioni di anni fa.
Un piccolo gruppo di Homo Habilis
sta attraversando la radura
sotto un sole canicolare,
quando, a un certo punto,
un predatore si para loro davanti.
È aggressivo, è minaccioso.
Fa quello che deve fare
un predatore in Natura,
quello che ha imparato a fare:
cacciare per sopravvivere.
Per il gruppo di Habilis,
questa è una tragedia;
ma è una tragedia conosciuta,
è già successo mille volte.
Qualcuno dovrà morire,
perché qualcun altro
possa scappare e sopravvivere.
Ma forse, questa volta non andrà così:
infatti il primo della fila,
quello più esposto,
quello più vicino al predatore,
decide di afferrare un bastone da terra
e a cominciare a farlo
volteggiare in aria.
Come una specie di ninja ante litteram,
comincia a farlo volteggiare,
a fendere l'aria, e a saltare, e a urlare,
e addirittura a pungolare
l'animale sul naso,
che a un certo punto decide di andarsene,
probabilmente più sgomento che impaurito.
A quel punto, mi immagino
che cosa può essere successo.
Tutto il suo gruppo si è fatto attorno:
e forse, in una protolingua
non ancora formata,
ha cominciato a chiedergli:
"Ma come ti è venuto in mente
di usare il bastone?
Non l'ha mai fatto nessuno,
ma come è possibile?
Ma chi te lo ha insegnato - e soprattutto,
tu lo puoi insegnare a noi?".
Io non so come può aver risposto
questo coraggioso membro
degli Homo Habilis;
ma sono sicuro che, da quel giorno in poi,
nessuno è mai più uscito
senza il proprio bastone in mano.
E sono altrettanto sicuro
che questa tecnica è stata insegnata
a tutti i bambini e a tutti i cuccioli
che sono nati in quel branco,
in quella comunità,
per molte generazioni a venire.
Quello che il nostro coraggioso
e temerario Homo Habilis
era riuscito a fare
è stato fare passare a un next level
se stesso e l'intero suo gruppo,
attraverso la modalità che è la nostra
effettiva specialità in Natura,
cioè noi apprendiamo.
Noi apprendiamo continuamente
nel nostro rapporto
con le sfide, anche estreme,
che ci vengono incontro
e che ci accerchiano.
E lo facciamo utilizzando
gli strumenti che abbiamo intorno,
e le relazioni.
Questa è la nostra specialità,
questa è la nostra dotazione evolutiva,
e ce l'abbiamo tutti.
Ricordiamocelo,
e teniamolo qui per un attimo.
Torniamo un attimo al nostro bambino.
A quel tempo, nella sua vita
arrivò la musica
e incominciò a prendere
lezioni di chitarra;
ma soprattutto, nella sua vita
arrivò il Buon Maestro.
C'è sempre bisogno di un buon Maestro.
Quel giorno, però, il bambino
era particolarmente distratto:
continuava a sbagliare,
e non trovava la nota,
e saltava delle battute,
e sbagliava le chiuse,
e sbagliava le aperture,
si indispettiva, sbuffava, ricominciava,
finché il Maestro non lo fermò
per chiedergli se ci fosse qualcosa
che lo stesse disturbando.
Il bambino non amava
particolarmente parlare -
preferiva scrivere, una volta -
però decise lo stesso
di cominciare a raccontargli
quello che gli stava capitando.
E fu una valanga di parole,
e fu un fiume di lacrime.
Dal canto suo, il buon Maestro
non staccò il contatto visivo,
nemmeno per un attimo,
come a tenerlo avvolto
in una specie di abbraccio.
E aspettò.
Aspetto che ogni parola si esaurisse,
e che ogni singhiozzo finisse.
Solo a quel punto,
il Maestro fece la sua domanda,
e gli chiese:
"Ma tu ti ricordi che cosa ci siamo detti
la prima volta che ci siamo visti,
circa il modo in cui
si impara a fare musica?".
Il bambino alzò lo sguardo,
come se nel cielo
fosse scoppiata una stella,
e rispose: "Una battuta alla volta,
ripetuta mille volte".
Il Maestro sorrise,
e non ci fu bisogno di dire altro.
Quel giorno, il bambino corse a casa
che sembrava un vento,
arrivò e trascinò la sedia
vicino all'esigua libreria di famiglia,
dove era sicuro che avrebbe trovato
una cosa importantissima,
e letteralmente si arrampicò.
Girò con il suo ditino, faticosamente,
tutti i titoli dei libri, finché lo trovò:
il vocabolario della lingua italiana.
A quel punto lo aprì, lo aprì a caso.
E lì cercò una parola altrettanto a caso,
e cominciò a leggere la definizione.
Ma era difficile,
perché anche nella definizione
c'erano parole a lui sconosciute.
Quindi decise di sedersi,
e fare questa ricerca ampia.
Cercò tutte le parole
di cui non conosceva il significato,
una dopo l'altra,
finché riuscì a ricomporre
il significato della prima parola.
Lì il bambino capì una cosa,
ebbe un'intuizione,
prese una consapevolezza che manterrà
per tutto il resto della sua vita:
che per definire una parola
bisogna convocarne tante altre,
e ognuna di queste parole
offre un pezzettino del suo significato,
per definire la prima parola.
Questo voleva dire,
nella sua testa e nella sua mente,
che il linguaggio, che la lingua,
sostanzialmente è una grande rete
i cui nodi sono le parole.
Lui doveva solo avere voglia
di arrampicarsi su tutta questa rete.
E così fece: per settimane,
forse per mesi.
I voti non migliorarono affatto:
ma il professore gliel'aveva detto,
il buon Maestro gliel'aveva detto
che i voti non sarebbero migliorati.
Ma lui continuava ad acquisire parole.
Dopo qualche mese, aveva un vocabolario
quattro volte più denso
di quello dei suoi coetanei.
E a un certo punto,
cominciò a sperimentare
di scriverle queste parole,
di accoppiarle fra di loro.
E prendevano forma, prendevano senso,
erano effettivamente connesse.
E cominciarono ad arrivare le prime frasi,
i primi periodi e infine le pagine.
E una sera, il bambino riaprì
il suo taccuino rosso
per scrivere della storia di un ragazzo
che doveva uccidere un gigantesco drago,
aiutato dal suo amico mago,
il buon Maestro,
che gli dava i consigli giusti
per poterlo fare.
C'è una studiosa e psicologa americana,
che si chiama Carol Dweck,
che dice che la nostra mente funziona
in una modalità binaria,
secondo due modalità
fra loro estremamente antagoniste.
La prima, quella che usiamo
in larga parte nella nostra vita,
è quella che lei chiama
"della soluzione del problema".
In questa modalità,
la mente va sempre alla ricerca
di ciò che già conosce:
delle esperienze che hai già fatto,
delle nozioni che hai,
delle sensazioni che senti.
E le rielabora per poter rispondere
a quel problema contingente.
Ma poi ce n'è un'altra,
c'è un'altra modalità,
che Carol Dweck chiama
"La mente che si espande,
la mente che cresce".
In questo ambito,
ciò che produce energia è la curiosità.
E la mente non va al suo interno,
ma va al suo esterno,
alla ricerca di tutto ciò
che ancora non sa,
di tutto ciò che ancora non conosce.
Ora voglio provare
a sintetizzare in due punti
quello che ci siamo detti fino adesso.
Il primo è che noi
siamo esseri per l'apprendimento:
questa è la nostra dotazione evolutiva,
ne siamo dotati tutti.
Noi nasciamo nudi, glabri,
incapaci di muoverci,
incapaci di coordinarci;
eppure la nostra mente
già da molto tempo prima,
si è attivata,
presa da questo afflato, da questo conatus
di voler acquisire informazioni continue,
e di apprendere.
Il secondo è che, in alcuni momenti,
la vita ci chiede
di trasformarci in modo radicale,
e noi non possiamo utilizzare la modalità
della mente che risolve problemi,
dobbiamo utilizzare la modalità
della mente che si espande.
Questo lo voglio dire, anche,
a tutti coloro che si occupano
di educazione, a diverso titolo.
Però, alla fine, chi non
si occupa di educazione?
Certamente un maestro,
un docente, un professore,
un pedagogista, uno psicologo;
ma anche un genitore, un cugino,
una zia, un amico.
Prima o poi, la vita ci affida
l'esistenza di una persona
che sta attraversando
un momento come questo,
e noi saremo chiamati a decidere
se vorremo essere più come la maestra,
o più come il Buon Maestro.
E che fine ha fatto questo bambino?
Be', il bambino è cresciuto:
non tantissimo, ma un po' è cresciuto,
diciamo comunque è diventato adulto.
È un grande esperto, dicono,
di tematiche di lavoro,
è un docente universitario,
è un formatore,
qualcuno dice addirittura
un consulente eclettico,
e giuro che nessuno li ha mai pagati.
Ma certamente, lui è un autore.
E infatti, quando qualcuno  gli chiede:
"Hey, ma tu che cosa fai nella vita?",
lui risponde, senza nessuna esitazione:
Io scrivo.
(Applausi)